so I just finished round two of the
Vegas super Swiss and this was a really
crazy game
um as we're gonna see I think the
YouTube thumbnail is probably gonna
share the position after move two but I
was playing Grand Master Daniel
Fernandez and I have a small tidbit of
uh of a story
um for those that maybe haven't been
super long time fans of my YouTube
channel one of the very first videos I
uploaded was playing a Blitz game back
in I want to say 2009 against Daniel
Fernandez at the U.S open but um that
was against International Master Daniel
Fernandez and that that's actually a
different player than who I played today
uh they they have the same name so part
of the challenge in playing Daniel
Fernandez was actually figuring out
which games is his and which are the the
other Daniel Fernandez but I was able to
tell based on his country because he
represents England and yeah I did a
little bit of prep operation although it
was very difficult to prepare for him
because he plays pretty much everything
like he's had so many games with E4 and
D4 and C4 and Knight F3 and within each
of these moves he plays pretty much
every line so I really didn't know what
to expect and when the round began he
wasn't at the board he showed up maybe a
couple minutes late and when he got to
the board he took about three minutes
before making his first move Pony for so
I wasn't sure if he was like trying to
play mind games or just not sure what he
was gonna play uh so I pretty quickly
played C5 this was part of my pre-game
prep
and then he took another bit of time uh
maybe like four or three four minutes
maybe more to play his next move and his
next move is like almost a novelty I
don't think it's ever been played by a
grand master before
Pawn to H4
and this is just looking like a complete
beginner move like what is this uh what
is this idea and I wasn't sure if it was
like pregame prep on his part and he was
trying to psych me out if he was
inventing this over the board if maybe
he had a little bit too much fun in
Vegas and uh somehow it got to him and
he decided to uh not control his
impulses but uh I was happy to see this
because it guarantees kind of an
interesting opening battle and a fun
story to tell
and um I had a few thoughts after seeing
this move first of all a few days ago I
I did this whole beginner bot speedrun
on chess.com I'll link somewhere for the
YouTube video but against all the
beginner Bots they were just randomly
throwing in like H4 and A4 in opening
positions so I thought that prepared me
for uh for this game but then the other
thought is that H4 isn't like a really
useful move at least so early on so it's
essentially like a reverse English
opening with H4 included and I was
trying to figure out the best way to
develop while trying to make it so H4 is
not so useful because usually in English
uh very often you'll find the king side
Bishop like G6 Bishop G7
um but then that would walk into Pawn H5
so I went for a different development
setup starting with Knight to C6 and he
played Bishop to B5
and here I played Queens of B6
and I was in a little bit of prep
obviously I didn't prepare this exact
position but I knew the idea is because
this is a line I play as white without
the inclusion of H pawn move
and I actually played this line several
years ago back in 2011 it was a final
round of the K-12 national championships
and I was playing the top scene on board
one at the time it was International
Master Mark Tyler Arnold and I beat him
with uh this queen B3 move
um so just reverse version and it was a
really nice game an idea of this move is
I hit the bishop and I want to avoid
double pawns so if Bishop takes C6 I can
take with the queen and then he plays
Pawn to A4 so I couldn't help like
silently laughing to myself because I
would not have imagined a grand master
playing H4 and A4 within the first four
moves of the game and this was known as
a crab when you you play uh both flank
pawn moves uh because the crowd likes to
pinch I guess from the sides and I might
as well say this now but within the next
seven to eight moves we're gonna see
white play the turbo crowd because
eventually my opponent is going to play
H5 and A5 so we'll see how that pans out
but A4 is very sensible defends the
bishop
um I was actually more expecting Knight
C3 which is a bit more multi-purpose
defends the bishop and controls the
center and there's actually a trap here
that I was familiar with from Having
learned the English opening I would have
played Knight F6 and if Knight to F3
black can win a pawn with Knight takes
E4 because the Knight is overworked so
if takes takes and if Bishop takes E6 I
can either take first or just take and
defend the knights
um but that didn't happen he played A4
and I played Knight F6 hitting a pawn he
played Pawn to D3 and then I play Pawn
A6 so trying to force him to decide what
to do with the bishop
um either to take or to move back and he
thought for a little bit and then ended
up taking I took with queen and then he
played Pawn to C4
which at first glance like if we just
see what White's done in the opening uh
it seems like he's violated a lot of
opening principles by uh just moving so
many pawns especially the thing pawns
and then trading off the only developed
piece uh so white has nothing developed
after the first seven moves but C4
actually makes a lot of sense because
white no longer has a lights red Bishop
it's really up to the pawns to fight for
light squares and C4 does slow down my
idea of playing Pawn to D5 now I really
wanted to play Pawn D5 to try and open
the position because I do have the
bishop pair so for that reason I played
E6 here and he played Queen to F3 so
maybe trying to discourage Pawn D5 but
I'm still able to play it
and here is feeling really good because
D5 is well supported and if white plays
E5 I can just Retreat and hit the pawn
and I was thinking this is just a very
pleasant position
um but he didn't play E5 he played
Knight to C3 and here I had a decision
to make the first glance it seems like
black should open the position because I
have the bishop here so taking on e4 or
C4 seemed to be the more natural moves
but the more I thought about this
position the more I liked the move Pawn
D4 which I did end up playing
and the idea is black is just grabbing a
long-term space advantage and even
though it closes things down temporarily
which usually favors nights I thought
white would be very cramped because
after 92 White's pieces are kind of
clunky uh all on the king side and my
full information does restrict the dark
Square Bishop and I thought long term I
can eventually activate this bishop with
ideas of B5 or an eventual F5 but the
bishop on B7 so I thought it's still a
very rich position with a lot of natural
plans for black and then here
um I play Bishop D6 natural move in some
sense preventing Queen G3
uh he played Pawn to H5 which was a
little bit unexpected but okay trying to
make use of the early age Pawn Advance
maybe going for H6 to induce some
weakness on the king side uh so I played
Knight D7 essentially removing the
Knight as a Target on the king side and
I thought this was a nice multi-purpose
move because now if he plays H6 I can
safely play G6 and not worry about the
queen hitting the knights and then on
top of that I'm preparing some ideas of
F5
um at least unleashing F1 and I'm also
having ideas of Knight E5 to the queen
and a Pawn on D3 which is a potential
weakness
um in White's position and then he plays
Pawn A5 so rather than developing just
trying to grab space with the
um the flank pawns and it's hard to
punish such a strategy because the
center is closed
um it's essentially taking time to grab
space on the sides and I really tried uh
to explain this as best as possible and
here I play Pawn to B5 which aims to
open the B file one way or another white
can capture this pawn two different ways
he took on passant which I did not
Overlook I took back with Queen
and another thing I didn't Overlook here
is it looks like white has a tactic Pawn
E5 hitting the bishop and The Rook
um but this would actually be a big
mistake for weight because after Bishop
B7 I saved the Rook I hit the queen and
then E5 is hanging Queen G4 hitting this
Pawn I would take and defend the pawn so
instead of playing Pawn E5
um he played Queen to H3 so at first
this looks a little bit strange because
what is a White Queen doing on edge of
the board but it is getting out of the
way of the F Pawn and the Knight so
white has ideas of f4 and Knight F3 and
just completing kingside development and
here I began smelling some blood like I
was really sensing that black can pounce
in the position and I started with the
move Queen B4 which essentially takes
away White's casting rights Bishop D2
isn't really playable because when I
take the pawn hit the rook and then my a
pawn in many lines is ready to bolt down
the board so it essentially forced King
F1
and I take away White's casting rights
and in this position I took a bit of
time because the move I initially wanted
to play probably what I should have
played was Queen to B3
and this is actually a made in one
thread I'm writing Queen D1 Checkmate
but the reason why I didn't go for this
is because white can play the move F4
and after Queen D1 King F2 I didn't
quite see a way to just maximize the
initiative here for black and White's
ready to play uh maybe not Knight of
three right away
um because the d-pawn is hanging but
something like Rook A3 and then
eventually Knights to F3 and I thought
my queen would be a little bit awkward
so deep in White's territory without too
many other pieces really helping out so
um after a bit of a think I thought that
it's a more practical approach to try
and just bust open the center when white
is a little bit still lagging behind in
development and I played the move Pawn
to F5
and this turned out to be a pretty bad
move
um because even though it seems logical
for for black to try and open the center
uh I'm also a little bit underdeveloped
and my king is a potential Target on E8
um so probably what I should have done
was been a bit more patient maybe play
Queen B3 castle and then later play Pawn
F5 but after I play Pawn F5 uh he found
a really strong response is to start
with taking after it takes what I had
mainly calculated was if white takes on
F5 then I have a nice move 95 hitting
the queen and there's some fun lines
here like if Queen E4 I can just castle
and Sack The Rook because then Bishop B7
and uh the Queen's just getting trapped
if it takes takes this is pretty
crushing for black because t3's a just a
huge weakness and also have Queen A7
there's Bishop B8 and the Queen's not
escaping
but um
this didn't happen because the app Pawn
is essentially poisonous 95 would be
really strong response uh what I
initially missed is that he has this
move Bishop F4 and I completely
underestimated the fact that
white gets a ton of initiative because
my Bishop's attacked I have no Defenders
of the bishop and rookie one is coming
very quickly and what I initially
thought is that I can somehow win B2 and
just hit the Rook but I actually have no
time to capture on B2 because if I if I
take right away rookie won and I'm
actually in trouble
um I don't think there's a great move
here for black
and after what I played in the game
Bishop takes F4 light takes F4 I still
can't really take on B2 because Rook E1
and there's no good way for black to
have check
so
um I had to do a bit of damage control
here as after Knight takes off four I
Castle but now we're gonna see white
getting a lot of initiative he plays the
move Pawn H6 and uh I was feeling bad
here because I was really trying to
create a situation where the H Pawn
wouldn't be useful for lights and now
it's one of White's main attackers uh
just about to tear apart my king side if
I'm not careful so uh thankfully I have
the move G6 trying to close things down
creating the pawn chain and even though
G7 is a pretty big hole um and if queen
queen lands on G7 it would be checkmates
it is hard for white to get the queen
here so soon but then he finds a strong
move Queen to G3
and this move creates a threat of Knight
takes G6 and it also creates an awkward
situation for me to try and defend
because if I allow Knight takes G6 uh
then imagine takes takes made his coming
and if I play the move Rook F6 then
there's rookie one and yeah rookie ideas
it just seems very very unpleasant not
to mention Knight D5 is a fork so uh
yeah this would not be good for black So
eventually I decided on 95 which defends
the pawn and aims to get the Knight to
G4 where it can block the queen along
the G file but then he keeps initiative
with rookie one and after Knight to G4
he played the move which I just
completely overlooked and I think like
when we got to this position I just
assumed that everything is covered on
the king side but then when he played
his next move I realized I might be in
like really big trouble
Knight takes G6
um and usually when the Grand Master
plays such a move you know that
something is uh a little bit wrong so
the Knight is sacrificing itself
essentially to make way for the queen
along this diagonal
and I thought for a while here and I
realized I don't really have anything
better than to take the knights and
after I took the night I actually
thought I was still surviving they
played the move I expected Queen to G6
and here white has two threats
um Queen takes G6 which is a simple
Maiden two threat King h a queen G7
checkmates and White's also threatening
Pawn H7 to Chase the king away from
defending the Rook
so when I calculated this variation I
thought I had a move to just save
everything let's move Rook to A7 and um
there's a line here I want to show
because I played this move I thought
maybe he overlooked a really cool idea
um further down in one of the lines is
at first it looks like white can play H7
um to again just try and win The Rook I
should mention after Queen G6 King h8
I'm pretty sure Bach is uh surviving
here so Rook is just a key defensive
player guarding the seventh rank
but in the event of Pawn H7 at first it
looks like black is just losing a lot of
material was after takes takes the king
is overworked and then takes takes and I
had calculated this line and saw that
there's a saving resource for Black
Knight H2 check given the Rook is no
longer on each file this is actually a
really nice resource forcing King E2 and
then at the very least black has a draw
here because Knight prevents a king from
running to the king side has to move to
D1 and then I have some Perpetual
um maybe I could play for a win
um yeah actually the engine is saying
black is better oh but now it's saying
it's a draw so yeah it's only black who
can maybe try and win this
so I was excited when I saw this line
but to my horror there's a different
move for white after Rook A7 white does
not need to cash in right away but
there's a move Rook to E7 and I actually
realized this shortly after I played
this move and when this came on the
board I realized I'm in very big trouble
because if I take then Queen takes and
my pieces are just not in any shape to
defend why threatening this and if I
play this there's Pawn H7 and just
everything is crumbling for uh for black
so rookie seven happened and I realized
I have nothing better
than to sacrifice my queen and I was
wearing I was actually wearing my oh no
my queen hoodie but same design uh merch
command in the description if you want
to get some uh some merch I'll probably
have a Vegas coupon code so if you want
to save on merch use coupon code Vegas
you'll save some percentage off
uh but yeah the this oh no my queen
moments uh happened after I played Queen
to B6 which I thought this only moved to
just try and fight and keep the game
going because I do defend the G the G6
Pawn through x-ray vision and after
Queen takes B6 which he played at the
very least I win
um I win the rook and I also have a
bishop for the queen
um the problem here is I just have a lot
of Pawns falling
um but when I went into this line I
thought that after Queen digs G6 King h8
maybe there's some counter play to play
Rook afe8 and then try and Checkmate but
he played a very accurate move rather
than taking on G6 he snagged the pawn on
C5
and um then D4 is attacked and my Rook
is attacked and after I play Rook
effiates threatening made in one
he saw the threats and just played
Knight F3 and at this point there's
really no counter play for black and my
d-pawn is falling not to mention white
still has a massive attack on the king
side so I played a few more moves Bishop
B7 H7 King h8
Queen takes D4 Rook G7 uh now there's no
more battery so my hope is running out
he played Knight G5 threatening very
devastating kind of smothered mates in
the corner so I play Knight E5 breaking
the pin
um and then he plays Pawn F4 and here
it's just about over because if my
knight moves really anywhere then Knight
F7 is checkmates uh my Rook is pinned
and the pawn the each Pawn that moves on
move two has become a very powerful
force in the position
so I played uh I played Rook D7 here and
after Queen C3 Rook takes D3 uh there's
just not enough counter play because he
plays Knight F7 King G7 and then h a
queen and I thought this is a A fitting
finish given that his H Pawn which
looked very ridiculous on the second
move as H4 move the H Pawn turned out to
be unstoppable and turned into a queen
even though both Queens are hanging for
whites I don't have a queen of my own
and I resigned here and it was a sad
finish especially because I think I was
in very good control earlier in the game
um I think the turning point was when I
played this Pawn F5 move I just
underestimated White's chances to get a
huge initiative and credit to my
opponent he really pounced on it and his
creativity of moving his h and a pawn so
early in the game it payoff so what to
do
um it's still a fun game I'm not too
disappointed uh there's still what seven
more rounds to play and the next game
starts in less than two hours so I'm
gonna wrap it up here try and find some
food to eat
um I do want to note that this game was
being broadcast live on my twitch
Channel with commentary from Jonathan
trentz I do appreciate everyone tuning
in I did a hop on call with him at the
very end of the stream to give my
thoughts but definitely tune in to his
commentary uh he'll be commentating the
morning games of each day so it's 11 A.M
Pacific for the next I believe four days
uh so yeah thanks so much for watching
if you have questions or comments leave
them below don't forget to get merch And
subscribe and I'll see you guys in the
next recap